hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report competition it's everywhere it's
on the genetic level it's on the
macroeconomic level it's on the
microeconomic level in it morphs that it
transmit eights and it has all kinds of
weird corollaries and we're seeing all
interesting fauna and flora and fauna
what hey what's going well definitely in
our world global financial system we
have predators and ghouls and this is
something we have talked about for a
long time many of these predators and
ghouls are the captains of so-called
industry which is no longer really true
we only have financialized rackets right
and so we're gonna look at some of these
ghouls and how they think and how they
basically predate upon the entire
population and that is our business
model first of course the US Commerce
Secretary will burrow us in the past
week he told Maria Bartiromo that the
current the corona virus in China will
help accelerate return of jobs to the
United States this is of course very
black plague like when it did help the
middle class back then because everybody
died a third of the population up to a
half died in some places right right
this is kind of what I was talking about
you know in terms of the competition
that's happening on the genetic level is
happening on the macroeconomic level and
the micro economic level because Wilbur
Ross is basically right and there's
nothing wrong with that because we're in
a globalized competitive marketplace and
China chose to build their economy in
such a way as that spawned the crisis of
the coronavirus and for that there is an
economic penalty and the US could
inherit a benefit of that economic
penalty similarly the u.s. built its
economy in ways that cause other kind of
externalities that are highly
detrimental to the US economy but all
these countries are pursuing economies
that are globally malevolent in some way
and we're at the end of this globalized
period or at D globalization D
valorisation depopulation because all
the economic models follow around the
hyper financialized and place no value
on humanity I think that's pretty clear
at this point and so now we're seeing
the result of that and remember
competition extends down to the genetic
level you know as that famous book The
Selfish Gene talks about you know the
the virus wants to live right so I mean
we're competing with the virus and so
it's the competition is now it's it's
morphed into something really quite
amazing I think of course we do have a
just-in-time delivery system and you
know in terms of bringing this
manufacturing jobs back to America
thanks to you know an epidemic hitting
China the fact is while China might be
able to build a factory in ten days we
may take you know ten months at a
minimum certainly over a year with
planning and regulations and all that
sort of stuff also like much of our
industrial heartland say Ohio
Pennsylvania places like that well
they're getting or you know destroyed
and devastated by the opioid I'm a depa
Demick and here is a fascinating thing
because remember every single individual
in the economy and a financialized
economy they have to maximize profits in
it so for all the you know working-class
underclass really the African American
black American very poor white people a
lot of them just get thrown into prison
because those that's huge profit Center
for corporations then you have these
guys who used to work in factories and
now they're suffering out in the
heartland and what they got fed what the
algorithm fed them was opioids because
it was huge profits electronic patient
record systems used by thousands of
doctors were programmed to automatically
suggest opioids at treatment thanks to a
secret deal between the software maker
and a drug company right so again this
the competition on the cellular level
the software level the macro the the
micro economic level so here you have
corporations involved in brainwashing
and they're involved in distorting our
information field they're involve
in adversely programming their computers
to to to prescribe opiates to patients
for profit even though it's killing more
people than we lost in Vietnam so you
have to ask yourself is it the disease
that these American corporations have
the CEOs the brain diseases and the
psychosis that's competing for
domination it's not on the human level
the human level is gone as a humanist I
guess we're posthumanist and ours just D
constructionists we're looking to tear
apart the fabric of humanity the fabric
of our culture the fabric of our bar
existence and we're seeing that really
being sped up in real time with the
assistance of computer it's its
disintegration as a service so also with
a predator based system where the apex
predator constantly gets fed and anybody
else in that ecosystem is penalized or
punished so here we have two groups an
opioid manufacturer and an algorithm
provider and the algorithm provider you
would think if they they programmed it
to over prescribe opioids which killed
up to 70,000 Americans per year so they
did that they intentionally basically
did something that would result in the
death of tens of thousands of people you
would think like say el chapo el chapo
he got sentenced to how many lifetimes
in prison well here's the Department of
Justice on what happens to these apex
predators Department of Justice Office
of Public Affairs electronic health
records vendor to pay 145 million
dollars to resolve both criminal and
civil investigations so this is for
practice Fusion incorporated they've
agreed to pay a hundred and forty five
million dollars for these 70,000 a year
back ten years up to ten years so you
know that's almost close to a million
people they've killed directly who knows
indirectly as a result of this of like
family disintegration and stuff right
and of course that's no penalty at all
170 million dollars hundred and forty
five million dollars one hundred and
forty five million dollars of course you
can be borrowed from the central banks
at 0% interest and you could construct a
forgivable loan that never matures so
it's free there's no penalty so I think
you know this is the Lord of the Flies
on a global scale right if you put a
bunch of if there's no if you have the
worst most sadistic person in charge
like an opiate drug manufacturer and you
gave them unlimited money at 0% interest
rate they will cause a genocide right so
this is opiate genocide as a service as
a profit Center as a business it's much
worse than what we saw us 80 years ago
so this financialization has how we've
gotten around the right to pursue life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness is
they always say it's the algorithm here
it was the algorithm that did it we
didn't know that our algorithm was
racist or classist
we didn't know that we didn't you know
it was algorithm we are not responsible
that's why these sort of guys get away
with you know what would normally be a
crime in the hood like anybody who's
poor they would actually do 20 30 40 50
years and somebody would collect the
profit on incarcerate them but here so
you have these algorithms are the ones
that deep platform us the algorithms are
the ones that package these
mortgage-backed securities and saw the
biggest wipe out of not only black
American wealth and history but the
wealth of many people they lost their
homes it's still like down so they blame
the algorithm they themselves never have
any responsibility because of course we
introduced legislation like the
dodd-frank act to force them to have
responsibility but now there is no human
individual that ever for these people
ever it takes blame it's always the
algorithm right so it's death by
algorithm and you see this thing for
training all aspects of the economy and
if you program a gun to shoot somebody
who's responsible for that crime is a
you the guy who programmed a gun to
shoot somebody or is it the guns fault
because it had the program to shoot that
person so the logical person would say
well the person
the gun is guilty of murder but here
these opiate manufacturers is saying
we're not guilty just because we
programmed the computers to kill
Americans
we're not guilty because it was the
computers that did it was the inanimate
object that somehow just decided one day
and that's as I said at the top of the
show that this is competition on the
algorithmic level on the genetic gene
level because we've got viruses that are
not just a corona virus but we have we
have mental pathology and psychosis has
become a competitive force a lot of
these executives should be in
straightjackets and thrown into a mental
institution but there they've been given
unlimited amounts of free money and
they're sadists so what do you think's
gonna happen
remember at the top of the show I said
Wilbur Ross is like happy that they're
coronavirus is wiping out people in
China because it might be good for us
jobs so here we have Goldman Sachs
articulating something in a debate on
their own letters to shareholders that
wouldn't see them big deep platformed if
you ask this on Twitter or on Facebook
or YouTube you the individual who's not
Goldman Sachs would be the platform for
asking this but Goldman Sachs asks in
biotech research report is curing
patients a sustainable business model
and they ask this in an April 10th
report entitled the genome revolution
the potential to deliver one-shot cures
is one of the most attractive aspects of
gene therapy genetically engineered cell
therapy and gene editing however such
treatments offer a very different
outlook with regard to recurring revenue
versus chronic therapies said Sylvain
Richter in a note to clients while this
proposition carries tremendous value for
patients and society it could represent
a challenge for genome medicine
developers looking for sustained cash
flow and he cited a Gilead treatments
for hepatitis C which they used to earn
about 12.5 billion a year but it's now
down to about 4 billion because it cured
people right it's curing people a
sustainable business model according to
Goldman Sachs that's a question yes
ok now the perfect example you have a
sadist a sadistic organization Goldman
Sachs they're given unlimited money
billions hundreds of billions of dollars
and pay no interest on that money to to
to introduce genocide as a service right
so there are the Genesis
business is thats goldman sachs
definitely predatory behavior that this
is this is their mindset they're looking
for profit so as we saw in the testimony
when they were packaging those
mortgage-backed securities that they
knew we're gonna wipe out your pension
fund they knew it and but they said it
was the algorithm selling this and the
pension funds wanted it they wanted this
risk so we have predatory behavior
wherever we look okay let me just jump
in for you attack CEO plasmosis is that
brain the psychotic episode one has if
you imbibe cat poop yeah right and a lot
executives on Wall Street purposefully
do that they eat cat poop to to instill
a sense a to to engender taxi uh
plasmosis so that they can act without
empathy and reap profits and they're
given by society by the bank's unlimited
free money to do this ok so what do you
think the result is gonna be Oh
genocide is a service and Goldman Sachs
should have a much higher multiple
because there's still six billion people
out there they've got growth but at the
top at the end of the day when all of
the money is held by a few apex
predators they do start going after each
other so you do have the opioid
manufacturers and they make big money
huge money that algorithms that tell the
doctors to prescribe it but you might
not have a pharmacy to go get the
opioids because many ohio communities
are becoming pharmacy deserts thanks to
CBS which is buying clothes in local
pharmacies and manipulating Medicaid to
lower reimbursement rates below cost for
Indian pharmacies so CVS is a competitor
to the small local pharmacies but CVS
the pharmacy benefit managers they get
to decide how much an individual
pharmacy collects from Medicaid and
they've been basically making sure their
competitors make no money at all from
any pharmaceutical benefits so they're
putting them out of business and now you
have pharmaceutical deserts across
America well outside of the you know the
winner locations that Hillary Clinton
would call them well the parts are worth
more than the whole right our organs as
a human being sold separately on
sigh like eBay are worth a lot to a
goldman sachs we're gonna take a break
when we come back much more coming your
way welcome back to the Kaiser report
I'm Max Keiser time now to turn to David
Morgan of the Morgan report David
welcome back max for every back
all-righty first of all I want to say
this at the top of this interview I
think there's a strong possibility that
silver outperforms Bitcoin in 2020 and
this would be the first year really
since 2011 when we first started
covering Bitcoin at $1 we started buying
and telling everyone to buy it at $1 but
I think it's gonna outperform Bitcoin
this year David Morgan your thoughts
well I'm slightly shocked to say that
max but I do think it's gonna be a great
year for silver I think everyone that
follows silver closely knows about Scott
me nerds from the Guggenheim fund
manager well very knowledgeable he
talked about you know his number one
asset picked this year's silver and then
he was asked why and he said it was very
undervalued he threw else at the goal I
do think the potentials there max and I
hope you're right I think it's possible
I think bitcoins moved I don't fault
that closely but I think we're backed up
and then like the 8,000 range there's no
bond around the 3,000 range so it looks
like it's running out of a little bit of
momentum here and double from here it'd
have to be the 16,000 for silver to
double from here we'd be looking at what
about 34 I don't think either the one of
them are gonna double I'm looking for
about 30 percent move and silver this
year from where we are now and Bitcoin I
really don't know when I look at rhodium
and platinum and other metals that are
in skyrocketing they seem to be
telegraphing the collapse of the fiat
money around the world more assiduous
Leora studiously or some other multi
palapa Sabich world that I'm going to
put in there because they are not as
manipulated whereas gold and silver are
manipulated because the central bank's
hate when people buy gold and silver
because they like to push their Fiat
junk
onto the world but silver wants it busts
through and the demand for we've talked
about this since by silver crash
JPMorgan once then once the buyers of
physical silver get to a certain
threshold that the central banks lose
the ability to manipulate her anymore
it's gonna gap to sixty bucks I mean
that's kind of my thought about silver
and that's why I think the could
outperform Bitcoin in 2020 but let's
talk about the feds expanding its
balance sheet with the hundreds of
billions of dollars in repo market
intervention the yield curve is inverted
if even briefly once again so the the
yield curve around the world is
telegraphing global financial collapse
because the short rates are higher than
the long rates that tells us that banks
don't trust each other enough to lend
money to each other and they they're
injecting hundreds of billions of
dollars they don't call quantitative
easing for but they are injecting you
know hundreds of billions on the repo
market and it's not working right I mean
the dead patient is even deader than it
was you know six months ago David yeah
because everything you said max I mean
if you want to go back to my history
like fifteen years ago we were having
more crises and I put a lot of white war
and I just put up through her trust I
said the whole system is built on
confidence and Trust and the banks are
trusting each other when this breaks
down you really see some remarkable
downside to the equity market the bond
market financial markets in general and
that was well before the 2008 crisis we
basically went off the cliff and came
back from my steadied opinion but right
now I just want to reiterate what you
said there is a mistrust bank to bank
and that's failure when these banks
don't trust each other and they're not
going to loan to each other overnight
and they don't trust another bank to
loan overnight I mean that really spells
trouble ahead and most people are kind
of blowing it off that you know we could
print our way out of this no country has
ever been able to print their way out of
this if it were true Zimbabwe would be
the richest place on the planet right
now right well let's talk about Boeing
for example for an example right so the
stocks trading at
close to 50 times earnings and it's
quadrupled since Trump took office and
because they are a state sanctioned
monopolist in the defense business and
America likes to bomb people so hey
let's buy some Boeing but because they
replaced engineers that know how to
build planes with financial engineers
who know how to milk and manipulate
balance sheets and Accounting Standards
a lot of their planes started falling
out of the sky but nevertheless it is
the darling of Wall Street and the worst
things that happen at the company the
more the stock price goes up so is this
just more of the same in terms of fraud
and manipulation or have we kind of
flipped as a society psychologically
where now we are we are valuing stocks
based on how much damage they do so in
other words because Boeing does a lot of
damage that's the value metric now not
price earnings not cash flow not nothing
nothing like that we're only valuing
companies that kill a lot of people and
they get a higher p/e is that what I'm
saying I'm not sure that I think you
made two points I want to comment on
both number one is that 40% of the GDP
basically of this country is based on
financial movement I mean an auto call
auto companies aren't auto companies yes
they build automobiles David I know that
but they're basically finance companies
everything is built on the credit system
and you pointed it out very accurately a
Boeing and how are they valuing the
stock I don't know there's algorithms
out there there's no i7 same four years
about three years ago I started stating
that there is no correlation between the
general equity market basically say the
S&P 500 and a physical economy and at
one time it was very closely tied I mean
the whole concept of the Dow Theory had
to do with the industrials of Trance
rotations and the utilities all being
full sectors of the economy and those
numbers reflected how well the crown was
doing in those three sectors that
doesn't exist anymore
we're in this lala land and you picked
Boeing as a perfect example max and how
do you value a company that's doing
worse physically and yet the stock price
continues to go up I think I share
madness and it to me it portends that we
are at the end of the Age of Empires
right there involving coin clipping as
we know which is the same thing as
printing lots of worthless fiat money
but in the case of Boeing and it's
interesting because the if I were you
know convicted of committing lots of
murders and I was sentenced to jail and
my defense was well I'm gonna buy the
jail and I'm gonna free myself okay so
here yeah Boeing that is obviously
complicit in a lot of really bad things
and their answers to buy back their own
stock right so they're saying like you
can't hurt us because we're just gonna
keep buying back our own stock at a rate
so fast and MIT drives up stock price so
high that we're going to you know claim
immunity from prosecution because we're
buying back our own stock right now
stock buybacks used to be illegal
because it's a form of inside
information now of course it's legal as
a way to anesthetize executives who can
buy back their own stock to avoid jail
we you know it where's that and David
well does the word Enron mean anything I
mean it's it's sad it's it's pathetic
but it is a reflection from my
perspective on the greater situation
should we find ourselves in not only in
the States but globally we are in the
propaganda press very little truth leaks
out suddenly shows like yours and others
that are willing to stand up and talk
about the financial terrorism that
exists throughout the entire system and
that the end is nigh I don't think we
have another you know three years four
maybe until something takes place and
maybe it's already taking place as we
speak I don't know what I do know
that these things do not end well and
the truth comes out
you cannot have a stock situation
described with Boeing and have it go on
forever because the truth is they are
doing very poorly with this 737 problem
and you know everything that we know
about this company and just because
they're pretending that everything's
okay and have the financial printed
money to make it happen on a short-term
basis doesn't mean that the end of it is
going to be let's say in a just
situation right well in the case of
Boeing right so Boeing Airlines
thousands of Engineers are fired so they
could they could afford to buy back
their own stock right their product
planes start crashing so but their stock
price went up so I mean who even covers
that on the regulatory front is it the
avionics industry that covers this this
crime is it the Securities sec I'm not
sure exactly where this falls regulate
what the regulation the spoof covers
this crime is it it's just in between in
between regulatory agencies like guess
they're just playing an arbitrage where
they figure that nobody in the SEC and
nobody in the FFA FAA that doesn't come
under their purview so they're free to
you know do what they're doing so
finally in 2020 David you know we talked
about gold and silver a little bit your
thoughts on the bond market in the stock
market I'm pretty certain stock market
is going to start lower this year it
might make one last up to another new
high and I think they'll be the
exhaustion it may have already exhausted
I think the bond markets more important
as I've said for years very difficult to
put a handle on that I mean everyone
that's in the bond market that as any
significance knows what the game is it's
nothing to do with long-term capital has
everything to do with what the interest
rate structure looks like and they're
betting on which way interest rates are
going to go
and that's really sad in a way because
it's come a gambling casino rather than
the basis of long-term careful formation
to build the infrastructure build out
the physical economy in a way meaningful
to society at large it's basically a big
casino now and at some point someone's
going to be on the wrong side of a bet
or someone's not going to be able to
make good on a bet because they can't
and all of a sudden this thing unravels
rather rapidly that's what I see in the
future when I don't know right well you
know they're called bat super reservoir
viruses I think that would be an apt
description of the balance sheet of the
Federal Reserve Bank it's just a
reservoir of viruses all right well
that's gonna do it for this episode of
the Kaiser report with me max Kaiser
Stacy Herbert like to thank our guest
David Morgan of the Morgan report until
next time bye y'all
[Music]